okay why don't we go ahead and get
started people here can hear you fine
great so gives me gives me a great
pleasure to welcome old friend and
colleague actually I'm old correct
longtime friend dr. Kevin Johnson who I
think most of you know is the chair of
the department of biomedical informatics
at Vanderbilt University one along with
ohsu one of the great informatics
programs and they do a lot of great work
and some of which will hear about today
kevin is a physician by training he did
his medical school at Hopkins did a
residency in pediatrics and then what
the heck I'll used the same joke I used
last night he he did informatics
training at a obscure university down
the coast somewhere near San Francisco
the Stanford or something like that
anyways it worked just as well today
yeah I gotta come up with new jokes
anyways anyways Kevin in his early
faculty days was at Hopkins and then was
recruited to Vanderbilt and they've done
amazing work there and we'll hear a
little bit about it including some of
the involvement in precision medicine so
as always this conference is being
extreme and Kevin knows that so I'll
have to be careful on things you might
say just among friends and then for
those who are out there listening if you
have any questions you can tweet them
with a hashtag demise comp dmic e co and
f and we'll add them into the mix if any
come in
and then this talk will be archived and
available on our website like it usually
is so take it away Kevin thank you my
glee pin helps feel free so first of all
thank you all i was really exciting to
be here both because you managed to let
the sun stay out for just a few hours
yesterday so that i could see it which
is really nice also because i have a
chance to visit a lot of old friends and
make some new friends i noticed that
this room has a clock it's way over
there and it says 1033 so it's an hour
off if I seem like I'm running too long
and this is one of the times where I've
actually put in enough material that I
might run long then I apologize i'll
start speeding up and trying to tailor a
few things I wanted to talk with you a
little bit about precision medicine and
this idea of what role we need to play
to target the data and the informatics
to do what the president and what the
country would like to see us do in the
space bill was kind about his
introduction i will say that another
philosophy that I've had to live by for
the last five years as chair is that
those who can do and those who are
chairs talk about others work and so I'm
going to mostly be speaking about the
work of others but I'm also going to
stay at a fairly high level because
there are some there are some
philosophies in here that I'm hoping we
can discuss if we have time at the end
so by the way this is a picture an older
picture I have of the street going to
Cannon Beach so it's a little Oregon
this front in there so I'm going to talk
a little bit about the definition of
precision medicine and the aspirational
goals then I'm going to talk about the
infrastructure that's necessary to
support precision medicine and how we
move from aspiration to reality
primarily looking at some examples at
Vanderbilt so I apologize for the single
site study but I wanted to sort of give
you a general sense of what we've been
thinking about and we've been a leader
in this space so I feel a little bit
more comfortable using Vanderbilt
examples but feel free to help embellish
if there's something that you want to
make sure I cover that I haven't the
definition that you'll find for
precision medicine right now that comes
right out of the NIH page is a precision
medicine is an emerging approach for
disease treatment and prevention that
takes into account individual
variability in genes environment and
lifestyle I was really pleased that they
extended it
two genes environment and lifestyle for
each person this is the picture of our
departmental brochure and we we actually
had a big fight in our department about
whether we were going to have our
departmental brochure have a great big
huge chunk of DNA or a person pixelated
into lots of little pieces which kind of
improv Uman or this and we actually
never are settled the argument so we use
two different covers but the idea of
this cover was to bring together the
idea of people their environment and
their and the host factors that make up
health and disease and if you think
about what we're trying to do with
precision medicine it's really treatment
and prevention taking into account all
of these different layers so average
evidence-based care done appropriately
is good for somewhere and around the you
know no distribution around the middle
specific phenotypes that differentiate
us in the room are important our genome
is important our environments important
our social and behavioral determinants
are important and choice is important
and all of that is a part of what we're
going to be trying to advance in
precision medicine so if you're thinking
about this from an informatics
perspective you can actually imagine
roles that any one of us in our field
he'll be playing in this entire spectrum
and there may even be others as we'll
talk about today so in the interest of
trying to get to some of the more
interest fun parts of the talk I'm going
to skip through a few of these slides
and this one I'm going to sort of just
gloss over and say precision medicine
actually has a fairly long history in
this country as defined by the Obama
precision medicine initiative mostly in
the space of cancer and in the space of
using pharmacogenomic or using genome
informed medicine for pharmacogenomic
medicine and brian druker who was one of
the early people who you might know from
the ohsu knight Cancer Institute proved
that it was possible to develop drugs
that could target just a malfunctioning
part of a cell that is causing cancer to
grow so this is something that actually
has roots here the problem that we are
trying to solve and precision medicine
is primarily sort of three areas one is
treatment for diseases that were
previously untreatable sometimes
diseases are untreatable because we're
using the average treatment plan for a
very specific
set of phenotypes that once we learn
more about the disease is absolutely
treatable sometimes it's untreatable
because there's very few patients with
the disease and both are examples of
what we think about in precision
medicine avoiding unnecessary costs of
ineffective medicine and then moving
beyond as we called it average care
medicine point in jay shendure this
slideshow showed up differently than I
wanted so let's start there so this was
on the first of the series of workshops
that were put on by the NIH in response
to Obama's request for the precision
medicine initiative and the reason why I
feel a little bit comfortable talking a
bit about Vanderbilt here was that
Vanderbilt wasn't back the site of the
first workshop because of work that
we've done in this space that they
wanted to showcase especially around
cohort development and data analysis and
prediction and this is a this is one of
the panels that was put together Francis
Collins is on the end here is Jay who's
a precision medicine person from the
west coast as some of you may know not
from here and then in the middle there's
a guy named Josh Denny who is right
about there who's one of our faculty at
Vanderbilt and really the whole purpose
of this session was to begin to sort of
unpack what is it what is it going to
take to do the the initiatives that were
part of the precision medicine request
by the NIH in one way to think about
precision medicine and the components of
it that relate to informatics are on
this slide and there really are three
and you can see them all here this is a
paper that came out in Jamie Oh earlier
this year and that is that to do
precision medicine you have to recognize
this learning health system that care is
informing research and that research is
informing care and there's three
components to that one is what we can
get from our patients past present
future and as you can see on the left I
would assert that the way we get that is
primarily by developing this cohort the
other is how we go from data to
knowledge and that's a classic example
of what many people in the room have
totally they're already doing which is
hypothesis generation work and expertise
and getting at these data to understand
what they're trying to tell us and then
the last is knowledge to action going
from something that we'd like to see
happening to getting it to the sharp end
of the needle
or if you will right at the point of
care that's advanced clinical decision
support and obviously a big part of what
many of us think about in clinical
informatics certainly for those of you
who don't know about Vanderbilt's
history and the reason why I think it's
important that on my you some of these
examples Vanderbilt actually from the
very earliest days actually developed
its clinical systems from a single
purchase which was right here called
Mars which is actually the University of
Pittsburgh's longitudinal repository and
when dr. bill stead and Randy Miller
first came to Vanderbilt there was no
electronic health record in 1991 and
over the first few years what they did
was they had a relationship with this
system called MOOC to bring the mars
system here which was then recast as
star chart and was essentially for those
of you a little bit of technical stuff
for those of you who know about it was a
no sequel repository that allowed us to
store any kind of information scan
documents unstructured stuff highly
structured information labs voice files
anything and on our model for holding on
to it was the belief that any of those
things could at some point be signal and
that we would have to use informatics to
extract the signal from that noise and
in fact through that process we
developed all of these applications if I
were to blow this up we've built we've
had applications and essentially three
streams the middle is all the clinical
apps the top is components that we've
built in our research Enterprise some of
which you've heard of and the bottom is
actually in the educational enterprise
all based on the exact same methods that
we need to do precision medicine they're
all built on this ability to do the
kinds of information retrieval that bill
Kersh told us to do 20 years ago as well
as ways in which we can use natural
language processing categorization human
factors engineering work that Joe Nash
is done to help us understand things
like the best ways to do order entry to
avoid unnecessary and unanticipated
consequences so the way that we've done
that in our place and the way that the
NIH is proposing to do it is to create
this patient cohort bandar built that
patient cohort is called the synthetic
derivative we have about we have
somewhere in the neighborhood of two and
a half million patients data and that is
a de-identified
continuously updated version of our EHR
we are also moving to epic and so our
strategy is to not stop this which means
that anybody who has epic in theory
could do this epic actually comes with
some tools out of the box that help with
this so we essentially take the
electronic health record and we strip
away all medical record numbers we
actually hide in plain sight and
algorithm developed by a guy named Brad
Mahlon any patient identifiers zaatar
names or doctor names by essentially
replacing the ones we can with another
random name that makes sense given the
note so therefore if a name is in there
that's not that wasn't replaced it's
actually hard to find because it looks
like all the other names at that point
we take all that information we put it
together with clinical notes clinical
messaging orders diagnosis data tumor
registry data death index data test
results and on the far right we also
hold on to blood samples from each of
these patients and we use that to create
a system called bio view bio view has
all of our subjects with DNA we have two
hundred and thirteen thousand patients
right now who happens who have been
genotyped out of that two and a half
million that are already in the system
so it's a very very large sample of DNA
directly attached to a clinical record
that goes back more than 15 years an
example of what we've been able to do
with this this is a sort of classic g
wasps Manhattan plot I think you've
probably all seen this and Marilyn
Ritchie at our place back in 2013
published some results where they were
looking at a group of patients who had
abnormalities in their QRS which is a
part of the electrocardiogram and we're
able to find this particular variant
that I won't go into all of these
details here I just want to illustrate
the process and so we find this variant
which gets published in circulation and
it turns out that this is a variant of a
known sodium channel that's now
implicated in a risk for cardio a
cardiac arrhythmia that's the power of
being able to identify a cohort and then
do a G loss which lots of people can do
but the next step step is to say what
else can we learn from a population of
patients who have told us that this
variant might be significant and so what
we then do is we pull the electronic
health record of patients who are known
to have that bearing it and we actually
go across
all the known phenotypes in our
electronic health record and that's
called a fee wasps phenome wide
Association study and by doing that we
are able to identify all of these now on
sort of two parts of a Manhattan plot
all of these different phenome
phenotypes associated with that
particular genetic variant and in
particular some of them are not
surprising cardiac arrhythmia some of
them are a little bit more surprising
arterial embalming ambala I can't
believe what I'm saying that embolus and
formosus and Colossus diocese I'm going
to have to give up my doctor card so the
whole point is that the wasp is allowing
us to expand what we can learn from a
genetic variant and there are some very
exciting projects now that are coming
out one that Michael over here will be
interested in that has to do with some
of what we're learning about some the
genetics of eye disease and you read
some of Nancy Cox as most recent stuff
yeah so all because we're able to do
this with the same kinds of data that
you all have here so that's what the
president was talking about when he
talked about this initiative and the
major points of that initiative are to
expand the prevention and treatment
opportunities mostly or some of which in
turn cancer to create a national network
of scientists who participate in
biomarker discovery of that type 215
million dollars is going to go to
creating a million-person opt-in
identifiable and viewable repository for
discovery a bunch 130 of that's going to
go for the main court and about 70
million is going to go for cancer and
that's what we're doing so it's all
exciting there's lots of papers in this
area and this should be easy right not
even a laugh I become it well it's not
going to be easy there are a number of
steps we have to take to get from here
to there the first is the whole process
of what we say is discovering predictors
so this is where all of us who are in
data science or an informatics should be
getting really excited because this is
where we begin to separate ourselves
from biostatistics and that as opposed
to exploring the world and trying to
uncover relationships we are now going
to explore that world discover
relationships and then see whether we
can use what we discover and other clues
some of which may be data that we're not
actually used to discover the
relationship to predict and that's the
classic area of big data just to remind
people
big data comes in lots of forms if
you've all seen this before there are
three major B's of big data but there
are two others that are very important
for healthcare the 3 b's that are
important for big data in general are
the variety of data bill and I were just
talking about the fact that one of the
big challenges we have is that it is
important for those of us in health care
to help data scientists understand the
variety of data types in health care
about the volume of data well a lots of
lots of groups are used to volume but in
healthcare we have waveform data so we
could go all the way to real-time
analysis of waveform data from an
electroencephalogram or an EKG or any
one of a bunch of other monitors
including Fitbit type data and then
velocity these data come in very it come
very quickly and they can either be
large amounts of data very quickly or
very small threads very quickly either
way they're complex data to manage to
add to that there are two other v's and
those other bees are veracity which is a
really challenging problem in healthcare
that almost no one in data science
thinks about which is an enormous amount
of the information in an electronic
health record especially ten years old
is false because we will start by saying
a patient has x and then if you're a
natural language processor you just got
your phenotype right wrong because six
months later we actually did the MRI
that showed they had y which should
invalidate x which means you shouldn't
include them in both groups that's
really really hard stuff and then
vulnerability obviously if you could
make these data more available to do
clever things like mechanical turkeying
to figure out which population is
another I'll come back to that that will
be great but you have to take on the
risk that if those data were in some way
going to be compromised you have just
given away potentially identifiable
patient data to larger populations of
people who shouldn't have had it and to
illustrate that this is just one small
example from a study I did years ago I
was trying to identify all the patients
who had asthma by doing a natural
language processing exercise and the
electronic health record and we were
able to identify and this is from that
paper which is in a MIA from year two
years ago we found it turns out 13
different terms for asthma that in
addition to 55 or so different ways that
five percent of which had different on
descriptors for asthma so those terms
included asthma reactive airway disease
exacerbation status asthmaticus etc etc
etc and then we had all of these
categories for modifiers that turn out
to be really important if you're
defining an asthma phenotype and this
was a highly manual process and to this
day every person that you know or every
group that it's doing phenotype work is
doing the exact same manual process it's
an extremely hard problem to solve what
we do at Vanderbilt I mentioned that we
D identify we extract medications we
grab the concepts that are actually in a
note using tools that are not unlike for
those of you who use NLM tools not
unlike mm TX or meta map for those of
you who know so we concept extract the
text we look for exact matches superset
matches or subset matches and we
primarily take the exact matches you
look at negation functions to prove that
they do or don't have something we also
use where concepts appear in a note to
decide whether those concepts are
relevant to this particular patient or
for example if their family history or
past medical history concepts we also
use the fact that the same concept can
appear more than once in a note to
increase the probability of his veracity
so all about is work that we do up front
before we shove everything into the
synthetic derivative and that's what we
then use to build the rest of these
phenotypes I put up here that we've also
started this idea of custom classifiers
and that is there's information that's
actually in the electronic health record
that if you didn't look for it in two
places or more places you've never
actually find it a really good example
that a smoking step smoking status shows
up in parts throughout the electronic
health record it takes a fairly
sophisticated algorithm to prove that a
patient as of a particular time is still
smoking and so we have started to build
those types of algorithms and we're
using that for homelessness for smoking
cessation as the two big areas we're
also going to try to do it for
depression as a general way to sort of
say these are comorbidities that we need
to know are active at the time of a
particular other events as opposed to at
some point in the record
if you understand the decision I'm going
to skip this slide so the challenges are
discovering these big sub groups which
is manually time-consuming and
computationally very difficult
aggregating large healthcare data sets
have numerous challenges most of what
I'm talking about so far has only been
available data but if we decided to do a
project with Vanderbilt and OHS you even
even if we're both using epic it's
actually not twice the work it's way
more than twice the work because of the
amount of time we actually have to spend
mapping whichever concepts have been
chosen at at ohsu to do a particular
thing to identify a particular aspect of
a patient's chart and match that to
whichever one we have at Vanderbilt so
the more sites we have in a network it
becomes exponential and exponentially
more complicated to create that larger
dataset as I'm going to get to at the
end of this talk but I want to just
introduce it now we start thinking about
this we need to start thinking about
what I would call a healthcare data
ecosystem that's really going to be
required for what we want to do in this
country and precision medicine and I'll
show you why later what I was trying to
get at most couple of slides is
something that I think I've already
convinced you which is we have every
reason to believe that precision
medicine and these exercises will
demonstrate some value to a clinical
enterprise and those slides were about
erlotinib which is a drug that with one
of the first to be demonstrated to
actually have a difference in its
ability to treat patients who have on
there's now blanking on which term
applies our condition I guess is
melanoma is that right Michael thank you
this totally blanking on that for a
second too much talking today a lot nib
is actually has a different level of
efficacy for patients who have never
smoked versus those who have and it's a
great literature about that suggesting
the social and behavioral determinants
are part of precision medicine there are
two papers that came out in the last
year right after the announcement that
essentially are trying to challenge
should the country be investing any
money in this initiative and if you
haven't read these two papers i would
highly recommend it the paper that i'm
going to spend more time talking about
our seven questions for personalized
medicine which was a paper by jordan got
a lot of us like i think most of us got
a little bit
strated by the read of paper which was a
viewpoint about the fact that where we
are going with precision medicine may be
based much more on the sexiness and the
bipartisan pneus of it then by the
science of it we will see whether that
turns out to be true I think most of us
believe it will not be the key points in
the second paper were things that I
think we would all agree which is if we
start to look at the promise of
personalized or precision medicine the
reality is that the effect sizes in
other words the extent to which we are
able to ascribe the variation we see in
the phenotype based on the genotype has
been vanishingly small there are a lot
of reasons why that might be but that is
a reality and so we have to face that as
we move forward all of us believe that
environmental characteristics are likely
to yield a larger effect size but are
much more difficult for us to obtain it
requires the expertise in this room to
do it the other is that the trials of
genome informed care have been
disappointing and we have great example
of warfarin at our place and there been
a couple of other studies nationally
that show providers do do fraud fighters
will follow some of the advice about
warfarin dosing but it's not really
affecting the base INR that we obtain
and primarily there a lot of reasons why
that might be but it's just a points to
the fact that there's a lot of work
going in without a lot of outcome and
then people's perception of risk may
alter behavior what I mean by that is
how many people here are in 23andme a
few a few of us okay and if any of you
decided to jump off a cliff because
you've seen that you have some disease
that you can't cure in the next few
years I guess those people wouldn't have
shown up right because they've already
gone yeah so the whole point is you have
to understand these risks you have to
understand relative risks and you have
to know how to change given what we're
trying to do a precision medicine either
your behavior as a physician or your
behavior is a patient to accommodate
prediction our understanding of that is
still very nascent in this country the
other big area that's that's a part of
getting from here to there is changing
practice this is a New Yorker cartoon
that many of us have used for a few
years now which was this future where we
would go to the pharmacist with our
sequence and actually hand it to them
and that the pharmacist would then say
oh well based on that sequence this is
the drug unit well the reality is
that as long as that pharmacists had
absolutely nothing to do that might be
possible but the reality of health care
right now is that there's overwhelming
complexity most of us can remember seven
plus or minus two facts at any one time
when we're making a decision and just by
looking at the slides you can see what's
happening human cognitive capacity has
long ago been outstripped by the amount
of information we need in healthcare to
deliver average care now we start
personalizing that care how many pieces
of information will we need to remember
to make sure that this drug which
requires refrigeration shouldn't be
given to a homeless person and by the
way this drug only really works in a
particular age group and almost never in
an african-american on top of the fact
that we're trying to diagnose that's
precision medicine so we rely on things
like clinical decision support this is
an example of an alert at our place at
Vanderbilt for patients who are
receiving clopidogrel I won't go into
all the medical details this is a drug
that we give patients who have a stent
to stop them from clotting off their
cardiac stent and we we provide this
alert we provide an explanation it's
only going to fire on patients who have
had pre-emptive genotyping so we know
for sure this patient is at risk as
opposed to the typical alert where we
may know something about the average
patient that we don't know something
about this patient all we know in this
case is that we have an equally
efficacious set of alternative therapies
and there may be reasons why you would
choose not to give them to a particular
patient but mostly you should be
considering switching we would expect
that seventy percent of the time or so
when this alert fires people switch and
in fact the first patient that received
this alert we did a big story about it
so that we can talk about it and educate
all of our providers and we were all
very excited we then did a study to see
exactly what kind of an impact these
Mets messages had and what you can see
here is that the absolute best we did
after 12 months was fifty-seven percent
of the time did they switch and and that
was only for the patients who were the
most severe metabolizers for
intermediate metabolizers only about a
third of the time there's actually no
clinical difference between what
actually happens in terms of outcomes
with intermediate metabolizers and
severe hyper metabolizers and so in fact
we would have expected both cloves to be
a lot closer and what this spoke to a
little bit was how were we messaging it
but it also spoke to this set of
concerns cardiologists when interviewed
and we have same exact data for workmen
cited concerns about the cost of
alternative therapy challenges
communicating with regional physicians
in other words i'm just a cardiologist
this person has a primary care provider
who's going to be managing this they
won't know this drug I would rather them
make that decision than me sounds fair
until you're the patient who has a stent
thrombosis because your doctor was kind
of afraid to try the new drug difficulty
understanding genomic information that's
the sheet that we hand and gaps in
scientific evidence as barriers to the
recommendation so a number of things
that we learned through qualitative
research talking to the doctors who were
actually responsible for making the
switch so I think what that brings up to
me is the need for education so on top
of everything else we're trying to do to
move this forward there's a real mandate
for those of us who are involved in any
way with precision medicine to begin
socializing the concepts educating
people about the concepts hearing their
reaction and developing other materials
that help them help those people to
understand why this might be an
important aspect of their care last next
to last area is reinventing the work um
you know the reality check about health
care today how many people here are
doctors or nurses or in some way health
and health care ok so for the rest of
you everybody else these guys will
appreciate it the reality today is
everybody goes into a mouse medicine
thinking about this the White House did
right which is it's a crossword puzzle
my job is to solve the challenging
crossword puzzle given to me and at the
end when I when I've actually filled in
every white square we all declare
victory we've saved the patient's life
we go home that was sort of the
aspiration of most people who want to
healthcare but the real reality is that
we mostly play Tetris and for those of
you who haven't played Tetris the goal
of Tetris is not to get overwhelmed
right so the goal is never to say you
win because it always gets worse and so
this is health care
you see a patient you see a patient you
see a patient you hope you're on top of
it something happens to one of your
patients which upsets all of your game
and now you've got to get all the way
back down to that bottom level and it's
going to just keep happening and so in
that picture I then remind us of this
and this is another big challenge of
precision medicine because all I'm doing
is saying to all my doctor friends you
thought it was bad before I'm about to
introduce a hundred new attributes into
your decision-making and I really hope
you're going to be able to use all this
well because eventually you'll be
accountable for it and that's
essentially where we are with this right
now so there are some early studies that
are showing us some of those variables
this is a study by a tool beaut from a
few years ago 2014 and essentially what
this study did it was actually the first
study to show that an environmental
variable might actually be responsible
for preterm delivery and I won't go into
the details you can see the paper but it
points to the idea that just as we were
doing with fee wass where I take a
variable and then I go across a patient
population or anwar george ii wass he
was able to identify a cohort of
patients who had preterm delivery and
then a very clean cohort of patients who
did not case-control and to do
essentially an e wos an environmental
wide Association study to determine that
in fact environmental variables do in
fact impact preterm delivery that was
the beginning of a report that the art
institute of medicine now the National
Academy of Medicine just published may
be hard to read it's called cap
capturing social and behavioral domains
and electronic health records this is a
report that talked a lot about social
and behavioral determinants and strongly
recommended that precision medicine
think about that layer so for those of
us who always believed this was going to
be important this report does an
outstanding job of helping people to
realize where this fits in what we're
trying to do with precision medicine so
you know there's a lot of change here
there's a lot of change that we had to
deal with with physicians and nurses and
patients and I want to show a little
video have you all seen a few people
raise your hand if you haven't okay then
I'm still going to shove it all right
because what this video speaks to this
is a video by athenahealth it's one of
about three videos i want to show you
it speaks to the other reality and
healthcare right now so as we're looking
at all of the things I just talked about
with the number of new data elements and
decision support rules this is the kind
of material that's getting out there
talking about electronic health records
and patients honey look he's playing
doctor mm-hmm how's it going doc yeah
it's dr. all right that look at that
early tomo tilly that's from Athena help
they have a number of videos like that
and it caught on like wildfire and
everybody at our place laughed about it
because they said it's just so true and
so you take that and you start looking
at the other things we talked about and
to get from here to there a big part of
what we have to do is say how can we
automate some of these analytics and
this is the challenge to you all how can
we automate these analytics and present
smart choices for clinicians and not
overwhelm them with more us with more
data how can we collect these data for
machines and decrease documentation work
right because as we talked about a
little bit if you saw the film one of
the challenges might be well if I could
videotape every single document if I
could videotape every encounter I've now
gotten rid of the Athena health problem
right doctors go in they do their thing
nurses come in they do their thing whole
thing is videotaped we archive that
storage is relatively cheap and then if
somebody wants to challenge my claims
for that particular visit please go look
at the video the same way the police are
doing so I can do that but now those of
us who do research have to grab text
from a video hard to do very noisy have
to parse that text into concepts tons of
false negatives and false positives
which will make everything else we're
trying to do a precision medicine hard
so there's the balance and then how can
we integrate communication with the
electronic healthcare ecosystem this
whole data thing how can we communicate
how can we integrate that into the
workflow so that the EHR it doesn't have
to be responsible for every single bit
of these data every single place a
patient has been every single breadcrumb
we left behind Deborah estrin calls this
phenomenon small data which is
each of us all day leave behind some
data that we could potentially use in
healthcare I'm going to come back to
that but if we start wanting to do these
automated data collection strategies
you'd want to be having those data
collected for you so that some other
system could analyze them and determine
your risk so the next area is
understanding these risks and I won't
spend a lot of time on this because I do
want to show you these two videos it
looks like I'm doing pretty well with
time so does everybody know the story of
target in just a sentence or two target
was able to use the data I just talked
about to figure out before a father
actually knew it that his daughter was
pregnant and there's a great story
behind this and you can read about it if
you want to but the key thing is that we
know from studies that have now been
done in the cancer space studies that
are emerging in obesity studies that are
emerging and hypertension that all of
these different data saw all of these
different data silos will be useful for
helping us manage disease again it's why
precision medicine is such a hot topic
so there's an alternative perspective to
this and I want to make sure you will
get and then let's talk about it
hopefully and we have time at the end so
this is from the ACLU pizza palace this
is mr. Kelly yes thank you for calling
again sir I share your national
identification number is 6 10 to 0 for 9
9 9 8 45 dash five or six 10 is that
correct yes Thank You mr. Kelly I see
you live at 736 Montrose corporate
you're calling from your cell phone are
you at home I'm just leaving work but
I'm oh we can deliver to Bob's auto
supply no I'm on my way home how do you
know all this stuff we just got wired
into the system sir oh well I'd like to
order a couple of your double meat
special pizzas sure thing it'll be a new
$20 charge for those sir what do you
mean sir the system shows me that your
medical records indicate that you have
high blood pressure and extremely high
cholesterol the total is sixty seven
dollars even sixty seven dollars that
includes the delivery surcharge of
fifteen dollars to cover the added risk
to our driver of traveling through an
orange zone I live in an orange zone now
you do looks like there was another
robbery on montrose yesterday what I
want double meat well I'm sure you can
afford
sixty-seven dollars that you just bought
those tickets to Hawaii they weren't
cheap a oh but I see you checked out the
budget beach bum at the library last
week I'll get the sprout subs good
choice sir gotta watch that waste if
you're hitting the beach a 42 inches wow
that's how much just between you and me
there's a three dollar off coupon in
this month's total Men's Fitness
Magazine your wife Betty subscribes to
that right anyhow clip that and it's
1999 even whoa looks like you maxed out
on all your credit cards bring cash okay
want to stop this from happening so you
know when I give these talks about these
things that's one of the concerns it's
the privacy concern it's the misuse of
data concern and we're early enough in
the process that you can absolutely
expect as precision medicine moves
forward and people start thinking about
the kinds of data they like to collect
from this cohort that names of people in
the country that I could mention we're
really interested in patient privacy
rights that work would be the types of
people who would oppose that so just to
have a little fun with it I had a team
of people from our place create a video
using those same data elements for good
instead of evil so i want to show you
that this is very early warning team
next on the list is to discuss with Lisa
as you know she's a 58 year old who
suffered a serious car accident that
resulted in the left knee reconstruction
she will be in a wheelchair for about
three months the current plan is to
discharge Lisa attack to home and to
schedule physical therapy visits for the
next three months excuse me John I don't
know if you've looked at the new tool we
have but I have it here I was just
entering in Lisa's information we might
need to make some changes in our
discharge plan we're getting a home
conditions flag let me see yes the home
is a high-risk configuration looks like
she has a lot of steps to get into the
house she's also an industrial park area
with no nearby parking hmm getting to
and from her car might be pretty
strenuous for her she's overweight and
has been winded doing even little things
here in the hospital good pickup we're
also getting in an inactivity alert from
her
sighs sensor looks like Lisa often goes
to bed at midnight often not sleeping
well and is awake around six a.m.
however she is not truly active until
10am but often the activity stops at
three p.m. the other alert I see is a
non BCD prediction alert on the portal
she consented to an automated extract of
her food purchasing habits from her
grocery store and restaurant use habits
from her credit card it seems she eats
fast food over three times per week and
frequents a local convenience store
daily often purchasing beef jerky and an
energy drink I think we need to get her
some nutrition counseling as part of
this plan because if she doesn't lose
weight that knee is going to fail oh and
one more thing I see here on her
calendar that she has a trip plan to
Hawaii in four months we really need to
make sure she can travel by then hmm is
there any place she could else she could
go she's on a fixed income and has
reported difficulty paying medical bills
in the past year it seems that our
children come to visit her most every
weekend based on identification data we
have available they have houses close by
in a more affluent neighborhood it seems
her daughter Taylor's house is getting
all greens for rehab readiness
assessment garage parking few stairs
neighborhood with sidewalks Google Maps
is reporting a whole foods within two
blocks of her house perfect let's pick
the Lisa's family and see if Taylor is
able to work it out so that Lisa can
live with them for the next three months
for the grueling rehab period three
months later Lisa returns to Susan for a
follow-up lisa is happy and healthier
she's even lost ten pounds thanks to the
data available to Susan this story has a
happy ending so so I do that because I
want the I mean yes there's still some
giggles at one could have but I think
the idea is if you imagine those same
data being used for good versus evil you
can begin to see the promise of
precision medicine because all of those
data are actually currently available
for most of us right now and and that's
doable if we have the right group of
people thinking through it and actually
testing it to make sure that the
nefarious things that worry people don't
don't happen so because of that and
because of the way this initiative is
likely to unfold the nea the nih just
this week announced a series of centers
that are going to be focusing on ethical
legal and social impact of genomic
information that's this is the Sun
the primary goal products will examine
the use of genomic information in the
prevention and treatment of infectious
diseases genomic information privacy
communication about prenatal and newborn
genomic testing results and the impact
of genomics at American Indian and
Alaska Native communities that's the
beginning of what will likely be a
number of centers that will focus on
genomics and all of those layers that
you saw on my first pyramid and that's
going to be one of the ways that we
start to really understand the types of
concerns at groups like the ACLU might
have had about this volume of data in
the ecosystem being used for healthcare
so to get there from here to there we
have to we have to answer these
questions about the questions that need
to be addressed to improve perceptions
of risk versus benefit and we have to
decide how best to educate stakeholders
of our precision medicine so in
conclusion with a little bit of time for
talking after all the key steps that are
part of this initiative right now are
discovering predictors coming up with
strategies to change practice
reinventing the actual work that's being
done to support this in the workflow
understanding the risks and transforming
here so with that thank you very much
and I'm happy to answer some questions
bill question so one of the one of the
concerns you know that's sort of
reflecting on I think the you know the
kind of evidence-based view that a lot
of us have is when there's going to be
so many different variables in these
patients care how will we know which
decisions to make i mean you know like
we might i mean we certainly know from
before this era there might be a drug
that is effective against some kind of
to marina in a tissue culture or
something like that yet when you give it
to a patient there is either no benefit
or sort of adverse consequences and not
only that you know so that there's so
many different data points and so many
different potential treatments and then
then they start to interact with each
other how do how do we apply
evidence-based medicine in this new
world right that's a great question I
would summarize that by base
really saying recognizing that the
evidence is mounting and that the number
of sort of disparate areas that are
brought together in that evidence how do
we manage that well we tried to think
about that a little bit as an open-loop
problem in that video where we showed
the phone app that was just providing
data because presumably so one answer is
we provide the data and people can you
use it or not use it the other is that
we can begin the work of sort of
multivariate modeling so we hinted at
that in the video by saying that the
house was receiving a certain score in
terms of rehab readiness right so I
think some of this is going to be levels
of abstraction I think some of this is
going to be context-dependent we already
rely on a team of people in healthcare
and hopefully we will begin to think
about who should be receiving which
types of alerts which one's the family
should receive which one's providers
should receive which one's nurses might
want to receive this is clearly going to
be a problem that will have a challenge
scaling because we can imagine lots and
lots of ways these data could be used
and I think it's just going to require a
little experiment experimentation I will
say that this problem exists today there
are a lot of variables that we pay zero
attention to in health care you know
it's I mean a goofy example but an
example nonetheless is the chloride is
low and we simply choose to ignore it
and we'll ignore it for years and years
and years until somebody can't figure
out the patient's diagnosis and then
someone will go back and go you know
they've had a low fluoride for five
years could this be something like CF
for example so those those models are
around now but you're right it's going
to be a very challenging problem that
sort of answer the question it's a hard
but yes so this is from the
twittersphere which I'm monitoring for
you Kevin so it says could you address
the methodology and tools Vanderbilt's
using to extract data from scanned
documents okay the month and methodology
that were using for scan documents is
all on the metadata so we are not
looking at OCR we are only looking at
the metadata and so far that's been
adequate and what I mean by the metadata
in this case is dates and times of
scanned documents location from which
the scanned document arose so we know
which clinic it is the header for the
type of document it is echocardiogram
report and that that's enough
information to do some things with it we
have tried to use OCR methods and we've
actually tried to use additional
information contextual
you infer like which lab tests were done
so we also obviously have diagnose he's
attached to anything that was done at
Vanderbilt we haven't found those to be
initially been very beneficial we have
the ability because again the process
and it can talk about this much so this
is an opportunity to do it the process
of creating a phenotype so let's just
say that we want to look at patients who
have type 2 diabetes I mean I guess I'll
use that example start with so if one of
these patients are type 2 diabetes we
can go looking at their diagnosis codes
but there are a number of patients who
came from someplace else with type 2
diabetes and we had enough that was not
the reason why we saw the patient they
are in our hospital because let's just
say they have Hodgkins or they have some
they have an ulcer pressure ulcer in any
of those situations there will be text
and that text may say t2dm or dm2 or it
might say type 2 diabetes or it might
say nothing but we might actually do an
a1c right and what we do is we manually
go through the chart to look for all the
ways we connect we can find the
breadcrumbs in that chart to figure out
that this patient has type 2 diabetes we
actually then literally do a recall and
precision using that technique so once
we've hard-coded that and that's how we
establish a phenotype so in that
situation we do read scan documents to
see if we can find things the problem
with reading the scan document is if
that's the only place where we get the
information then it's not reproducible
it's a very difficult strategy so we
tend not to do that the emerge
consortium has also been looking at a
lot of the phenotype work we're one of
the few places that have been a number
of old scanned documents and emerge I
think maybe many sites are using OCR but
we are not there was another question
over here did you talk a little bit
about your experiences in moving the
patient cohort EHR from your home grown
to epic or what the stage of that is so
the way it's great question the
statement that i make in that regard is
that epic is not going to be our
architecture it's going to be a part of
our architecture our homegrown
electronic health record lives inside of
star chart the plan is to replace
everything above that with epic and a
feed star chart so all of the
connections from star chart to the the
SD as we call this pathetic
were the rd which is the the identified
version of the SD are going to persist
because they're already at the level of
star chart not the applications above it
so it shouldn't have any impact we
haven't started doing it yet one of the
biggest issues here that people bring up
is well your data are clearly going to
be different right there's no question
that headers will look different
stylistically things will be different
no types might be different and we've
been dealing with that actually for a
decade it's just a question of having
dictionaries and so we'll continue to do
that I am probably being overly
optimistic but we'll find it as we go
through the journey Oh since you're
moving he had charge do you have and the
star charts going to be essentially kind
of like the research database do you
have any plans to make this open source
or allow other people maybe who have
epic to connect with it or to build a
similar installation on you know inside
of it and then it would facilitate this
data sharing and collaborative cohort
building that you're talking about so
Frank it's a good question any any site
that has the ability to have MongoDB or
tools that are no sequel databases can
build a thing like Star Trek there's no
magic there the work to try to bring our
particular infrastructure over I think
is probably not necessary honestly
because it's not about the
infrastructure it's about the planning
it's about setting it up and making sure
that you want to do it and having the
discipline we've always created a
version of this thing that's helped a
record counter so that anybody who's a
participating on a project with
Vanderbilt can go into that system and
find out how many patients in our cohort
satisfy whatever their needs are but we
aren't we aren't planning to make the
data themselves open that's part of the
Covenant to the patients yep we will use
we will be using itv3 we actually do we
they do it for different populations so
I to be too is a highly democratized way
to get access to very specific data
that's been mapped to a very specific
data model or recall that everything I
said so far would we use highly
unstructured data so I to be too doesn't
work so well with unstructured data
you'll still need to have other tools
for that good question yes
it
yeah so this is a question about getting
the effect sizes that you need to find
differences in very rare paved
populations then lots of us are involved
with the undiagnosed diseases Network
many of us are involved with emerge and
almost all of us will be involved at
some point in what's happening in the
PMI all of those are designed to deal
with this problem so you're absolutely
right there are many many studies that
Vanderbilt will never have enough data
to support and why I'm such a big
proponent of us thinking through this
health data ecosystem is I don't know
that I want to call every single friend
of mine in every single academic
institution to find out if they can add
to that covert that is a strategy that's
been used if you nicked had a neti who
used to be at Stanford is now at
Columbia did a bunch of studies with
Russ Altman and the way in which they
were able to execute that studies which
studies where they did a preliminary
version at Stanford and then they
essentially shift those models to all of
the other sites that had data warehouses
to see if we could validate and then
some of us had to pull our sample so
literally he did the exercise you're
describing which is get a big enough
sample that I can prove that what I'm
seeing really really has sophistical
power we wouldn't want to have to scale
that for every single observation in
that group you're going to have to use
some tools the ideal model would be a
distributed query and response system
and for those who know I to be too that
would be shrine which allows you to
distribute out calls and get back
responses the beating the bd2k
initiatives which is the big data to
knowledge initiatives funded by the NIH
two of the groups are working on ways to
distribute these queries and to use a
much more sophisticated networking
strategy or data strategy than when many
of us already have so there's active
research in this area to try to solve
that problem without having to use your
friends and family approached you know
I'm Kevin my question is probably pretty
similar to aarons and it deals with
standards for sort of data and knowledge
representations we've had these in
clinical purely in the clinical world
for decades but when I look at sort of
what i would consider true
interoperability I think it's really
questionable for what for what we've got
interview last night they would have
told you there's no question
there's no interoperability yeah and
mentally we keep going and inside I
think sort of look looking ahead like as
in fermentation I sort of think that
well if we had pushed enforcement of
these years ago we'd be better off but
what I hear from the policymakers is
that we weren't ready for that and it's
it's you know things like that and so
I'm wondering as you show those curves
about how it gets exponentially
complicated with genetic data and
precision medicine how do you see this
playing out I mean is this something
that like what do you think is the
solution to getting these things out in
the real world on a large scale well
there's sort of two questions embedded
there one of them has to do with
adoption and the other has to do with
interoperability I think the harder
problem of the two is interoperability
as you pointed it out the adoption
question is a little bit easier to
answer which is we are notoriously bad
at adoption of new information we all
know the statistics about the time it
takes and the only way that that's
likely to change is going to be the ways
in which we democratize the availability
of tools so for example there has been a
push in the New York Times that a great
piece of efforts a few months ago that
if electronic health records became
service-oriented completely so
essentially think of it as a sheet of
glass when going out into the world to
get any question you want answered on
the data you have here it may be
possible for us to publish something
that we've just learned and publish the
service that can be picked up by some
group this is a totally different
infrastructure than we have it made
available to all of us to use it that
would be a way in which you could
validate it with another data set and
put it out there publicly and take
hopefully a shorter period of time than
12 years to at least let you know that's
a possible answer you can choose to not
listen to but when it comes to the
interoperability problem I think it's
it's not wrong to say that we weren't
ready because with fifteen percent of
the community talking about electronic
health records out of the hundred
percent that should be adopting it that
was very much akin to Mario Andretti
developing the car that you drive and
forgetting to put a cup holder in it
right so it was very much a time when
the community that really needed to help
us weigh in on what we needed to make
EHR is usable never saw them until after
mu1 so now we're getting a list of
information about what EHRs really need
we think from that group of people who
are now willing to help us to
to interoperability I think if we've
done it before there'd be just a small
subset of us who are sharing data but
nobody else will understand it yes
fantastic question I'm sorry that I
didn't bring a slide I'm just attempted
to go log into the portal we have a
section of our portal might call my help
at Vanderbilt where we show the results
of any actionable genotyped information
so we we sequester not actionable
genotypic information but once we have
the once we have the ability to use it
we show it and we show it in lay terms
using the exact same depth of
description that we have in the alert so
that because it's written in lay
language because most doctors or
basically lay people when it comes to
this the issue about provider or
patients who may not be a part of our
care network if they are currently not
in a situation where patients are
getting genotype elsewhere and having
available for us to see for their
annotated version of their genotypic
information or whole genome sequence or
exome sequence so what we do right now
is we genotyped those patients ourselves
so in essence we take ownership over a
copy of their genetic material they
don't we don't fear them an opportunity
to share it and because every patient
that's seen at our place has access to
the portal they then can take those
information that are actionable and take
them to wherever they want to take so
that's the best we were able to do think
we have one paper about that that's out
in translational is it sir I'm a little
curious about your use of environment
environmental information in that couple
of examples do you really think she'll
be able to successfully promote the fact
that we have the knowledge of the
configuration of your house and we're
going to use it ah yes I think I do have
a minute to show this video let me show
you my response to that in video form
thanks I'll enjoy that oh let's see
maybe it won't work
there is anybody who remember the movie
Sleepless in Seattle okay here's my
answer hi bye Jonah
shona hates remember this for those of
you who are too young talk to the person
that Jonah listen to me you don't know
Victoria I hardly know her myself she is
like bad mystery she tosses her hair
alone why does she do this no I did is
it a twitch need a haircut she was a
barrette to keep her hair out of her
face these are things i'm willing to get
to the bottom of that is why i am dating
her it's all I'm doing not living with
it not marrying hurricane can you
appreciate the difference this is what
single people do they try other people
on and see how they fit but everybody's
an adjustment so that's Tom Hanks's
definition of the scientific method and
I think part of the answer to this is
these are research questions I have
absolutely no idea but I think if we
don't pose these questions we don't
advance the science and and that's sort
of where I feel about it right now yes
so I think this connects a little bit to
the question Justin just asked and also
what Bill was asking earlier about how
are we actually going to take this
enormous amount of information and make
it actionable and part of that as you
said is abstraction but I think there's
this big emphasis on data-driven
high-throughput automated discovery I
really like the slide that you had with
the qualitative analysis of the provider
responses of why they didn't always use
that information that was provided in
the decision alert the targeted alert
and I was wondering if you could talk a
little bit about the potential role of
qualitative research or mixed methods
approaches in this everything every
single solitary study that we're doing
in this space of the mixed method study
every single one most of the studies
I've done for the last ten years have
all had an expense components so and
because how else do you want to see into
why and so I think it's essential the
only way that we're really going to
understand what patients are thinking at
this level and what providers are
thinking at this level is to come up
with a way to unpack their decision
making and to me a part of getting to
the answer to Bill's question is that we
are going to have to design
is based on what we are able to learn
through that knowledge acquisition task
that's part of message with mixed method
studies so good question thank you yes
Justin
this is actually a question from dr.
moham how are the physicians I know who
dr. mohanad based oh hey dr. Mohan how
are you glad you're listening on on the
stream go ahead what's your question
though so the question is how are the
positions at Vanderbilt adapting to the
change from a homegrown system to epic
we haven't we haven't gone live yet so
if you've ever seen the Gartner hype
hope cycle we are very very much at the
whatever the peak is before the trough
of disillusionment so so right now my
job is to provide a dose of reality but
to mostly encourage people to trust that
we're going to deliver something that's
at least as good as what they have now
we will see how well we do with that
that's certainly our goal and all of
this fits together because obviously I'm
very aware of national trends around
acceptance of commercially available at
electronic health records at the exact
same time that we're trying to move
forward with the precision medicine
agenda so our work is definitely cut out
for us because we do want to try to
continue to do all the things we're
doing the decision space now we have
about 15 active drug genome interaction
alerts that we're managing and we're
doing Studies on and we hope to have
about ten more a year so that's all
additional alerts we have to decide if
we're going to show less of the other
types of alerts that aren't related so
that page that doctors aren't
overwhelmed our over i rated
Vanderbilt's in the seventy percent
range as opposed to ninety-seven percent
because that's highly tailored alerts
but we could easily drive that up if we
start getting into alert fatigue and we
have to figure out whether that's a risk
let me go live without them so we're
thank you for the question it's a great
question we'll see where we end up
a good time for maybe one more yes oh
this is a bit reaching maybe but why the
focus on genomics all over all the rest
of the omics I mean there have been so
many jiwa studies that show all these
small effects and there's so many other
kinds of omics that seem like you know
metabolomics proteomics the microbiome
omics that did have precedent for having
big impact on patients health and why
aren't we talking about those things
when you're just saying omics in general
instead of so focused on genomics yeah I
can only speculate I think the answer to
that question probably lies and where is
the lamp post right so this is an
example that there is a lot of
information about genetics and there are
a lot of people well trained and how to
interpret those data versus the
information that's currently available
about homelessness or about any one of a
number of Social and Behavioral
determinants so I believe that as we
start to train more people there will be
careers that will spring up to help us
understand fitbit data and waveform data
and GM geolocation data we're starting
to understand that better and imaging
data another really big area every one
of those has a potential biomarker
waiting for us to discover it and
genomics is just right now it's really
easy that's I think that's my answer
other people never anybody else have a
belief about that but they want share
encourage looking in more of these other
places and that get a little too
complacent just because it's like you
say it like that metaphor where the
lamppost is but it's it's it's a
lamppost that hasn't to mix my metaphor
born as much fruit as we expected so we
should be expanding wherever larger yes
I could not agree more and I think part
of what you try to see what you saw me
doing at the end was trying to expand
our thinking a little bit about that
because I absolutely agree with
that's it you really better not it's
okay i have plenty to post and return
you